recherche jeune homme bien portant bon
état physique bon marcheur pas maladroit
pour poste deux mineurs payer 4 à 5 fois
le prix d'un ouvrier agricole
poste à pourvoir quinze jours par mois
en alternance avec quinze jours de repos
possibilité logement sur place transport
gratuit contrats à durée aléatoire voilà
si elle devait être publiée un jour ce
que pourrait dire l'offre d'emploi des
mineurs du kawah ijen
le kawah ijen le cratère vers en
javanais parce que la forêt en couronne
joliment les flancs mais à l'intérieur
dans la gueule même du volcan un enfer
une mine de soufre à ciel ouvert
tous les hommes des environs l'offre
d'emploi du kawah ijen la connaissent
leur père leur sont que leur feraient
rien un jour répondu ils les croisent
ont certainement sur le chemin qui mène
à la mine ils sont 80 cents mineurs peut
être moins ce matin à cause du jeûne du
ramadan qui commence aujourd'hui trois
heures d'ascension à vide autant pour
redescendre avec les pins de soufre brut
sur les épaules nous avons rendez vous à
mi chemin à la pesée avec kas rim un
piqueur de soufre qui doit nous conduire
au cratère mais l' os bada stream
on attend
salut
la bande à part
75 80 120 kg pour des hommes plutôt
frêle en général le calcul est vite fait
son bonhomme par jour qui font deux
passages à la pesée de 80 kg chacun en
moyenne cela fait plus de 15 tonnes de
matière première quotidienne
la bonne affaire pour un chinois
philippins qui tient la concession
ici pas d'horaires pas d'ordre de
passage pad équipe pas de priorité pas
de limites
vient qui veut prend autant qu'il peut
pendant toutes sa quinzaine à la mine
nous suivons leur route qui mène à
l'entrée du cratère à 2200 mètres
d'altitude
c'est dans les pas de stream qui nous a
rejoint que nous basculons à l'intérieur
du cratère du kawah ijen c'est d'abord
un lac d'acide le plus concentrées au
monde 200 mètres de profondeur trente
six mille mètres cubes de chlore fluor
et surtout d'acide sulfurique
wahaha
sous l'effet de sa propre chaleur le
volcan patienter encerclant le soufre
venue du lac à l'état gazeux qui se
refroidit à la fraîcheur de l'air le
soufre passe alors à l'état liquide
rouge orangé qui cristallise en moellons
d'un beau jaune canari des pépites de
soufre pur c'est cela qu'il faut piocher
et arraché en continu au cratère avant
qu'il ne s'étrangle de sa propre bave
que le souffre de son flammes et la mine
avec alors asri pioche épique temps que
dure son rôle on travaille aussi à la
mine
je gagne beaucoup dans le travail dur de
corps mais ça vaut la peine
en bas au village trouver du boulot
c'est facile mais ça rapporterait comme
une heure ici je peux tout m'offrir je
me suis acheté une moto je vais acheter
un mufle cultiver méchant mêmes déchets
et quand on a mal à la tête ou les yeux
on prends des cachets la compagnie nous
en donne gratuitement
pour accélérer la cristallisation des
vapeurs de soufre les mineurs post et
entretien des canalisations de fonte au
plus près des bouches jaunissantes du
cratère l'assimilé d'un meilleur
rendement
mais sous les pieds des piqueurs la
terre flirte avec les 4 son degré
souvent les vents tournants du cratère
renvoie comme ce matin la mauvaise
haleine de la mine au visage des
piqueurs d'abord les fumerolles sent bon
l'allumette grille et l'acide
chlorhydrique et l'acide sulfurique vous
inondent la bouche et le nez et les yeux
puis à le dioxyde de soufre le sulfure
d'hydrogène être vos poumons transperce
les vêtements vous colle à la peau la
sueur n'arrange rien
les larmes ses pistes à reims et la
brûlure des yeux et quand il n'y en a
plus c'est pire
on voudrait se passer la main sur le
visage pour tout effacer mais il y à
bien longtemps kasri mais les piqueurs
s'interdisent ce geste sous peine de
redoubler de brûlures j'ai pas peur
d'être malade a bien plus peur d'avoir
faim c'est vrai que je me sens moins en
forme qu'avant
c'est comme avec une voiture si tu tire
trop sur le moteur au départ ils te
feras pas longtemps et si tu la charge
de trop tu veut user la carcasse moi
c'est pareil je sais bien si je demande
3 mon corps à 60 ans je serai plus boire
rien alors que si je me ménage à 50 ce
sera encore d'attaqué après cinq heures
de fournès c'est la relève
a three mesure du cratère enfin et
retourne au niveau de la pesée où les
piqueurs se partagent une baraque à tour
de rôle les y campe sans eau ni
toilettes pendant toute l'heure 15 mai
avec un luxe insolent rappelé nombre
vite dormir un peu dans cinq heures à ce
rythme on redescend piocher
en taux travaille ici depuis peu porteur
jeune fort et beau comme tous ceux qui
débutent
quand je suis arrivé ici la première
fois j'ai eu envie de rentrer chez moi
immédiatement quand j'ai vu le cratère
et les pistes pour y aller c'était trop
dur je me suis dit je reste pas et puis
j'ai pensé à ma femme et mes enfants
j'ai tout ça pour eux la première fois
que j'ai porté du soufre sur l'épaule
c'était terrible et puis quand on la
pesée au poste il y avait seulement 50
kg le premier jour je n'ai pu faire
qu'une seule tournée le deuxième jour
j'ai voulu en faire deux mais je n'ai
pas pu rejoindre la pesée à temps j'ai
abandonné mes paniers sur le chemin je
suis allée les récupérer
j'ai passé deux nuits sur le volcan mais
quand je suis rentré chez moi j'avais
déjà trente six mille roupies dans la
poche 3 euros
tous les porteurs de charge le savent
sur le plat la meilleure allure c'est le
trop en emballant un peu leur foulée il
impulse au fléau de bambou un rebond qui
soulage les pôles une demi seconde
les chiens écrasés se soulage d'un rien
mais rien qui fait beaucoup après des
heures de marche
et puis c'est au trot que le porteur
réussi au moindre coût ce geste capitale
s'il veut durer à la mine
cette manoeuvre vidal avant que ne perce
aviv c'est et ce car le placement de
bras
81 kg bien sûr c'est fatigant c'est
épuisant mais j'ai toujours dans la tête
l'idée qu'il va manquer de l'argent à ma
famille par exemple pour la fin du
ramadan
on doit organiser une fête et en
marchant je calcule si je vais gagner
assez d'argent pour ça tout se mélange
je pense à ma famille à l'argent est
aussi ma santé et je me dis combien de
temps encore eu le courage de faire du
soufre pour les engrais les pesticides
la chimie local du soufre pour affiner
la canne à sucre que les paysans
javanais cultive plus bas en plaine les
utilisations sont multiples et la
demande toujours croissante
le camion de la compagnie charge à 5
heures tous les soirs au pied du volcan
les mineurs touche aussitôt leur dû
selon leur charge à la pesée 50 60 mille
roupies indonésiennes 4 euros
voilà la quinzaine est faite ce soir à
eux le bain la vire à moto la famille
retrouvée la partie billard et puis au
fil des jours le souvenir de la mine qui
s'effacent les douleurs qui s'estompe
juste assez pour avoir le courage d'y
remonter